Amen.
If you would be seated, we're gonna celebrate a baptism now
Church.
We get to continue to witness to God of just all
that he has done and continue to praise him.
And that's what Joseph is here to do.
Praise God for what he has done in his life,
that he is a name above all.
Names, friends. This is Joseph.
He's a master student at UCO.
Uh, and today he's gonna be baptized.
Let me briefly just tell you a little bit of his story.
He moved here a few months ago, about a year ago.
Uh, but long
before that, he grew up in a place called India
with a few people there.
Uh, and while he was there, uh, for until the age of five,
uh, Joseph went through a lot of things, uh,
grew up in an Indian, Hindu, believing family.
And until the age of five, he couldn't really talk.
Um, and they didn't know what was going on,
and they thought he couldn't talk for rest of his life.
Um, but yet, uh, he had grandparents who had came to faith
and started praying for him.
And then out of nowhere, just started talking.
God answered, uh, their prayer, uh, who had,
while still having parents who were following, uh, Hinduism.
And not only that,
after that he had even a longer path of just, uh, hardships.
Uh, one of those things was, uh, education.
The village that he grew up in, um, wasn't, uh, resources.
There pretty scars.
And there were, there wasn't a lot of, uh, things.
And so education was a hard thing to come by.
And, uh, English was another thing
that he just thought would not be possible for him to learn.
Uh, but, uh, and just God's faithfulness in all of that.
Uh, grandparents who were believers found a English Bible
and gave him an English Bible
and said, Hey, let this, let this be your teacher.
Not only was it teacher for him to learn English,
but yet to learn about Jesus
and what Jesus had done for him.
So he slowly started learning about what God, uh,
who God was and who Jesus was, uh,
and through all of those things, yet still trying to, uh,
survive in this village
and make it, and all of those things.
And then as, uh, that time went, uh,
he graduated from, uh, high school
and, uh, went to college, uh, had an incredible opportunity
and then even played, uh, some professional badminton.
Incredible. Uh, and so
after that, he was wanting to pursue master's degree
and, uh, apply to go, uh, to Europe.
And he thought he had, uh, a chance to do that
and got rejected twice.
And he was disappointed. I was like, man,
what did I do wrong?
Why was I rejected?
Uh, to go to Europe and had the scholarship
lined up and all those things?
And in God's goodness
and sovereignty, he made a way for Joseph to come
to the US about a year ago.
And that's about when he encountered some
of our college students, young adults,
international students who welcomed him with open arms, uh,
and started sharing the gospel with him, not only
by their words, but the by their works
as well, by their deeds.
And they loved him, cared for him,
and he got to see on full display
what the gospel was all about.
And then around last December, had the opportunity
to go to a cross gone.
And where he truly understood what had happened in his life,
and understood that I must pick up my cross
and follow him, deny himself,
and follow him with all of his mind and being.
And so, uh, it clicked in his head
and it's like, man, I, I surrender everything that I have.
And, um, after that, this Joseph started continued to meet
with some of our students and, uh, learn about who Jesus was
and how to follow him.
And, uh, came to me few, uh, weeks ago
and said, Shiva, I wanna be baptized.
I wanna declare of what's happened.
I wanna tell everyone that man, I, it's no longer I
who live, I have died to myself.
It's Christ who lives in me.
And so, Joseph, you are here today, uh, showing
the congregation here what's happened in your life
and just what an incredible testimony of
what God's done all the way from when you were young.
So Joseph, it's my honor, brother.
Then I get to baptize you in the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Praise God. Praise God.
Well, amen. Isn't that, uh, just an.